[Music]
so welcome thank you so much for coming
to my talk it's called against the
Burning Hells the apple sweet redemption
with Reaper of souls so really going to
talk to you guys this is going to be
very candid sort of behind-the-scenes
look at all the craziness that we as a
diablo team went through from launch all
the way until reaper of souls first a
little bit about myself i'm josh mascara
I'm the game director for Reaper of
souls and if you're trying to place my
accent I'll give you a little help
there's a little bit of English
obviously there's a little bit of
Spanish some French but it's mostly
mumbling so I'm sorry about that but
i'll give you the transcript of the talk
afterwards so what are we going to talk
about today what we're really going to
talk about how we as a team took this
journey from diablo 3 when it shipped in
2012 and all the permutations the
evolution are thinking how it changed to
result in reaper of souls and the
ultimate evil edition it's been a crazy
journey and it's really awesome to be
here to be able to share it with you
guys but first i have to disclaimers
that i think is really important for us
to get together on the same page the
first one I know might be easy for you
guys to think just because I'm up here
talking and because I was a game
director that I was solely responsible
for these changes that could not be
further from the truth if you played any
Blizzard game and seen her credits you
will see that the very first credit is
game design by blizzard entertainment
everybody at the studio had a role to
play first of all our team we fought
hard we had a lot of passion we knew
what we needed to do the other teams at
blizzard were brutal with her feedback
but they were also really supportive in
helping us make this transformation all
the way up to the leadership of the
company everybody understood what was at
stake and more importantly our players
were part of the ride we listened a lot
to the feedback you know and it was
really important for us to adjust adjust
and adapt to what they were saying
so really if I'm standing here today is
because I'm literally standing on the
shoulders of giants so I feel really
privileged to be able to be here today
the second caveat that I need to get out
there is it contrary to popular beliefs
we do have dates and milestones at
blizzard yeah it's true you might think
of course you can make this kind of
sweeping changes to your game because
you can take forever that's not true in
fact Reaper souls was supposed to launch
in November of 2013 myself and John
height who was a production director we
had to go all the way up to make more
time and we said Mike we need more time
to get this right and everybody
understood what was at stake you know we
knew that we hadn't quite hit our goals
with with the elbow three and Reapers
was our chance to right the ship and get
everybody reengaged with this awesome
franchise because yellow three was a
phenomenal game now the thing that
Blizzard will do is they will say if you
guys need more time and we believe in it
let's do it so we got a couple more
months they really made all the
difference that's where a venture mode
really sort of came together so again I
was part of a team and that team was
really important and we were given the
right support at blizzard so what are we
going to talk about today well I think I
actually want to start where diablo 3 is
right now today you know on the eve or
about the launch patch 22 we're really
excited but I think it's important for
you guys to really understand the scope
of this journey that you understand
where we ended up so what where is
Diablo well one of the things that
happened when I took over as game
director two years ago one of the things
that we felt was really important as a
team was to try to understand to really
get to the roots of what the Apple game
was all about now Jay Wilson who was the
original game director had an awesome
GDC talk about the Seven Pillars they
really defined and informed diablo 3 but
one of the things that we felt we needed
to do as a team and something that we
say a blizzard all the time
is we needed to concentrate the coolness
so we took those seven pillars and we
thought long and hard as a team and try
to reduce it to what we feel are the
three fundamental aspects of not just
reaper souls but of any diablo game and
these are the first one is you really
need to focus on the fantasy and for
diablo that means playing epic bigger
than life heroes fighting the forces of
hell and again reaper souls did a great
job here of pairing the crusader this
battle hardened you know warrior of a
tank against the only other villain in
the devil universe that could possibly
rival the apple in terms of coolness and
that is malthael the fallen angel of
death but the apples not just about
great heroes and these great villains
and the dark gothic setting which is
something that was really important for
us to recapture at the end of the day
the reason people keep playing our game
is because of the promise of epic loot
and this is where loot 2.0 which I'm
going to talk about in a bit this is
really where it came from this is our
thing we really needed to get this right
the second pillar they really informed a
lot of our thinking was we wanted an end
game for everyone whether you played an
hour 10 hours a hundred hours a thousand
hours of the elbow three we wanted to
make sure there was something for you to
do something for you to kill some
awesome loot to get and out of this
pillar adventure mode came out of so
there altima despression of go
everywhere slay anything and the final
pillar for us it because we
fundamentally feel that the a below
plays best when you're playing with
other people which is why on console
that same same screen same couch
experience are so important but the
final pillar was to make online matter
right again we really feel that when
you're connected with your friends
you're having fun together the magic of
the a blow bubbles up to the surface so
in this front we are the clans we had
two communities we had a bunch of co-op
buffs that really encourage players to
play together
so that's where the apple 3 is right now
the team as we're working on the next
patches we always ask ourselves what is
a fantasy why our players going to be
excited about playing this how do we
make sure there's something for everyone
and how do we really celebrate that
social experience so that's where we are
now how do we get here how do we have
why did we have to make all these
changes how why did we need to pivot so
much anything to do that I now want to
so go back in time and go back to the
year leading up to diablo 3 shipping so
i joined the team in May of 2011 I was
there for the last year and it was a
really awesome time to be part of the
team because there were members of that
team dating back all the way to Blizzard
North who have been working on this game
for over 10 years they have poured ten
years of blood sweat and tears and they
could finally see the end in sight even
myself had only been there a couple of
weeks I was really excited I could tell
that something special was going to
happen but I could also see again as an
outsider coming into this great team
that the specter of diablo 2 loomed
large over the team the pressure of
trying to live up to the legacy of this
incredible game weighed heavily on the
team and impacted so many of the
decisions but launch day gets coming
closer the team's excited we're wrapping
up the last iteration of the skill
system which was number 85 it was it was
crazy but everybody is looking forward
to this game not just inside the Buzzard
hallways but around the world you know
it's like it's finally after 10-plus
years of waiting there's a new diablo
coming out and everybody is excited even
on google we were that number five
ranked search for that year which is
pretty awesome so launch day comes right
and it's really a global celebration for
us I
as I mentioned a lot of members of our
team spent over 10 years working on this
game we had incredible launch events
around the world people were lining up
they could not wait to play the game
they have been waiting for this for so
long we as a team had been waiting for
this moment for so long and even in
irvine we had this great outdoor event
and one of the things that team did
leading up to this is for the last year
everybody was growing out these amazing
crazy beards and everybody shaved their
beards off on stage and it was really
this epic moment it was finally
launching but it was going to turn out
to be a dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde story right
on the one hand the sales are out of
this world I mean the sales team had
projected 6.66 million units in the
first year yeah I know even our sales
guys love Diablo right we got that in
the first couple of days like we didn't
like we didn't know what to think it was
it was mind-boggling right the reviewers
liked it I mean for Blizzard gain those
are actually really awesome reviews
right so things were good right no this
is the ugly side of it this is the one
that really hurted really stung and I
know I can see it from your perspective
oh come on Blizzard like you knew it was
a number five search on Google you knew
people were going to show up and play
well even armed what we thought was the
most outlandish estimates for day one
and then of being massively conservative
in reality and it hurt people have been
waiting for 10 years to play this game
and the worst fear of an always-online
game is not getting into play and that
is exactly what happened and the
internet did its thing
you notice I'm still not quite laughing
because the wounds are still still
really really really strong but I would
say all those hard lessons we learnt
because of error 37 there I said it I
can say it now good we put them into
practice and with Reaper of souls we had
the smoothest launch in Blizzard history
people were waiting on the front end
screen waiting to press play 12 of one
came around and they were into act 5
without a hitch right so we learned but
the damage had been done this game that
people were waiting for for 10-plus
years didn't live up to their
expectations and the sales didn't matter
the review scores didn't matter what
mattered most to us was a player
sentiment we had led them down and let
me tell you that felt shitty the entire
team felt the weight of that
responsibility so why were people upset
okay I think error 37 kind of gave us
one black guy but I think in retrospect
a lot of decisions leading up to d3
again you've heard the expression the
road to hell is paved with good
intention think every single decision
leading up to d3 in the moment felt like
it was the right one the team was
passionate about it or making it but at
the end of the day we made some mistakes
I think one of the first ones we made
was that we stuck almost dogmatically to
the structure of d2 in other words we
assume that was going to be okay for
players to play the same game over and
over and over again getting increasingly
more difficult right the thing that's
ended up happening is that players ended
up hitting a brick wall of difficulty
but the game was just funneling them
into increasingly more difficult
scenarios and on the story side no
matter how awesome your story is be a
hundred times spoilers sorry but it went
over three years uck and I you realize
it is being killed by butterflies and
you're going what the hell right because
no matter how great the story is if you
see the same thing 100
times over and over again it loses his
meaning so the game was hard again the
internet great source of honest feedback
and criticism yeah the most heroic thing
to do was to be the demon hunter and run
away from your enemies and this really
highlighted another problem we had
because the game was so hard instead of
being these epic heroes fighting the
forces of darkness you were barbarian
smashing pots that's right the best
heroes and sanctuary were farting
terracotta because there was more
efficient and less difficult than
actually fighting monsters that's not
what the Apple is about right there was
about killing demons and slaying the
avila himself and when they weren't
smashing pots they were trying to
optimize and find out the most effective
combinations of quest steps to get the
best loop so there were cases where
players would see this screen more often
than the actual game more often in the
actual pots they were farming because it
was more efficient as to jump into the
game kill the thing you were going for
and then jumping back out and then when
they were getting the loot right you
will see a bag full of yellows or a bag
full of legendaries and you would know
as you clicked on every single one that
you weren't gonna get an upgrade and a
true story on my live character my
awesome barbarian it took me a hundred
and four hours before I found my first
legendary I you know what it was a
quiver if you haven't played Diablo
barbarians smash things they don't need
a quiver full of arrows so something was
was wrong there and remember that moment
and remember that moment said like what
happened but that wasn't the end of it
so when you were getting the items in
game where did we send you to the
medieval version of ebay because that's
what heroic heroes do right when you
can't get the item from the pot you're
farming you go to to the auction house
now the auction house was this great
we had the best of intentions for it but
fundamentally and ended up
short-circuiting the core reward loop of
the game so what should have been this
moment of celebration this moment of
victory ended up being the lowest moment
for the team because we knew
collectively that even though we had all
the best of intentions that we had let
ourselves down we let our teams down and
we're letter players down but the really
special thing about the diablo team is
that instead of fracturing instead of
getting old bickering and losing faith
with one another we rallied around and
we told each other we can do this and
we're going to do it and that's exactly
what we did but to do that we really
need to it to understand where did we go
wrong okay we spent a lot of time you
know talking amongst ourselves talking
with other game directors have Blizzard
talking to Jay to really understand what
were some of our missteps and we sort of
summarized we sort of made three key
sort of philosophical errors the first
one was our whole sort of game design
philosophy around lunch launch we
misunderstood the player psychology it's
exactly like why do players play an item
based game and what do they want from it
and from a very practical perspective we
had the wrong type of beta test so the
first one lectris talk about items so I
remember joining the team and hearing
the designers get really excited because
they had set themselves a goal to live
up to the legacy of diablo 2 which meant
that people 10 years from now should
still be able to play the evil 3 and
still find items they had never found
before what I think as a team we forgot
our lost sight of was it that the diablo
2 that people remember was the diablo 2
after years of patching after an
expansion pack the team really believed
and work
hard and poured a lot of passion
thinking they could get it right on the
first go and what this resulted in was
this really long term item curve that
while the intention was to make sure you
still found something 10 years from now
the reality was that it was too stingy
players were not getting drunks and
that's why people love playing diablo
the other thing we thought was that
people wanted a hard a challenging a
brutal game and in truth what they want
is they want to game this fun the
challenges them but ultimately is about
trying to be as efficient and as quick
as possible in slaying all the things I
mean I even remember we did a
promotional video right before launch we
had our best players on the team talking
about how hard it was and how inferno
was just going to you know you know kill
everybody and we didn't realize just how
bad the experience was going to be
because of our stingy item curve one of
the other things was this notion of well
what if sometimes you will find a magic
item so a blue item what if it's
sometimes was better than the rare item
or a yellow item which should
theoretically be more powerful with in
that moment the surprise be a really
great moment for the player well that
just ended up being very confusing and
players didn't understand why an item
this should have been of lesser power
was actually better than an item they
should have been a greater power so
there was confusion around this concept
and this is one that it took us a really
long time to really come to grips with
we thought that because of the legacy of
Diablo that randomness is at the heart
of that experience right the randomness
is king the truth is that today we
understand that it's replayability that
is the goal randomness is a tool that
you can use to get replayability but
what ended up happening is that we ended
up sacrificing fun at the altar of
because we thought randomness what was
important an example here is what we
used to what we call near misses so this
is a quiver that my barbarian found or
one of them like it again barbarians
don't need a quiver the idea would be
here that oh I got an item for another
class oh that's a near miss and that it
could have been for me but it's cool
because whenever get to get to roll a
demon hunter in other words never I'll
be able to use this item right and we
didn't understand that all they were
doing to the players is not only did I
not get a good drop but you gave me a
drop for a class that I'm not playing
you guys are mean right I think a better
way of handling near-misses are
duplicates right because that's actually
in your miss I got a different version
of the same item that means the next
time I might get a better one because I
can actually use it the other thing is
we thought aren't loot fountains awesome
right let's just throw all the loot at
the player right because it's going to
be so much fun to see this happen except
when the reality is that you're seeing a
bunch of junk and don't get excited
those orange gloves if they read as
orange on those monitors they may be
legendary but they're not for your class
so don't worry about that so it was just
you know we were compounding issue upon
issue and one of the reasons we did this
is again we misjudged player psychology
and I think one of the key things when
designing an item based game is you
really need to sort of balance or at
least be aware of the reason why players
play your game at first like what is
that fantasy you're trying to sell to
them and then is how they actually play
the game and these two are very
different so the fantasy we want to sort
of sell our players that we want to
deliver for our players is you want to
be this badass demon hunter you want to
do wield crossbows and slay all the
demons of hell and get all the great
loot right that's why you play right
this is an aspirational character she's
a badass I'm gonna kill all the demons
so that's why we play how we play is
very different especially in this day
and age you go to Google you ask Google
what is the most
efficient way to get gear and you get
over half a million responses right so
instead of players who are really
exploring your game and getting getting
to fall in love with your systems they
are short cutting it right from the
get-go and this is something that d2
when it launched they didn't need to
content to us much as modern-day item
based games need to you because not only
is it a few keystrokes away twitch and
YouTube are really sort of telling our
players it's not about the fantasy it's
about how you get those items so and
again one of the things that you know we
serve totally misjudged player
psychology is instead of playing the
game because of the difficulty of the
game the stingy Gnaeus of the loot we
were funneling them into a shop into a
store again not very heroic and then
when they were actually playing the game
they were flip farming right they
weren't actually engaging in the story
they weren't paying attention to the
wonderful world details we added they
were just going in going out so that was
I was terrible and this is where things
like the AL Kaiser run came up her this
is the most efficient way to farm diablo
3 when it shipped and the final
realization we made is that we really
had the wrong type of beta now I'm going
to as a bunch of spoilers here so for a
game that was supposed to have item
content for over 10 years you know for a
game that was going to have all these
different classes are beta consisted of
the first 45 minutes of the game and up
to level 12 there is no way we could
have tested any of these systems in
depth even though a blizzard we did a
lot of company alpha tests and we did
all these things there was no way we're
going to get any real actionable
feedback and the reason we did this is
because we felt that these spoilers of
learning the Canes going to die that
leah is Diablo we're more important to
protect right then making sure that our
item based game was properly balanced
and rolled right so what we had was a
demo
nada beta and again for reaper souls we
pivoted on this we had a prolonged beta
we invited as many people as who wanted
to join our game and the only thing we
kept for ourselves was the malthael
fight and you know what happened when we
launched sure enough when you get
hundreds of thousands of players playing
a boss fight they found a lot of bugs so
we had to fix it so again it's I think
for a game we all know the importance of
betas but it's incredible how even us we
made this mistake of focusing on the
wrong type of beta so what changed right
so we've been talking about you know all
the challenges the team faced launched
very quickly in the summer of 2012 we
knew that we needed to do things we knew
we needed to try to adjust knew we
needed to try to get the ship back on
its course so we started patching the
game we started listening to a lot of
feedback former players and the team
poured a lot of passion right and a lot
of energy to try to pivot the right way
to try to make the kind of changes that
not just our community wanted from us
but that we wanted from us well the best
thing about our team is we never gave up
because we knew we could solve this
problem and one of the things that
helped us was perspective and we really
got a lot of the perspective from the
console version now when we started
working on console they were just three
of us as myself Norbert Savile who's our
programmer and Julia Humphries was a
producer and I still remember to this
day my very first day of blizzard and
I'm sitting down with you know Jay
Wilson ray gresco Rob part all he's
hasn't and they're essentially giving us
our marching orders and it was very
clear as it like guys we don't know if
this is going to work right it's a test
it's a gamble you guys are smart let's
see if you guys can figure out if you
guys can get a Diablo game on the
console but the only thing is that if
it's going to work it's got to be
awesome so whatever you need to change
change which is both incredibly exciting
as a game designer
but ultimately terrifying here you are
getting the keys to the kingdom in the
car and all you have to worry about is
not wrecking it so that was that was a
little bit terrifying but again
something we did from the start is we
try to really define what are pillars
for the console version work so we had
three pillars the first one was pick up
and slay we knew that for this to be a
Diablo game we knew we had to keep it
fast we needed we had to keep it
visceral and we needed to stay true to
the action RPG aspect that is the Apple
we knew we go in we were going to have a
challenge when it came to the user
interface but we what we did not want to
do was to simplify or dumb down the
experience what we wanted to do was
streamline the experience so we kept the
players in the action as much as
possible the second pillar it was really
important for me was it was hand-built
for the console a quick shout-out who
here played at the Apple game for the
first time on console awesome thank you
right because we knew that we were going
to get a slew of new players who've
heard about Diablo I never had a chance
to play it and now they're gonna be able
to play from the comfort of their own
couch with a control in their hand so we
knew that we didn't want to make a port
in fact port was a dirty word for us
right what we wanted to do is really
deliver a handcrafted experience and we
changed so much about the game the
camera every single skill in the game
has been tweaked so that it feels great
and responsive on the controller right
we changed the way the difficulty system
work so many things really deliver a
handcrafted console experience but the
most important pillar for us was the one
that really expressed what was uniquely
console about Diablo 3 on the
PlayStation and that is one couch to
rule them all we knew that if we could
get four players sitting together on the
same couch having beers playing on the
same screen that we would have a very
console way of experiencing the Apple
free it's a lot of technical challenges
we needed to overcome
again it was important for us because we
as I said before playing together is the
best way to play diablo 3 so why did the
console version of the game give us as
fresh perspective well because it
allowed us to really challenge a lot of
the assumptions that the core team have
been operating on there sometimes like
by second nature in terms of how you
control at the Apple game what loot
means in the diavel game and
fundamentally how a double game looks
like moving the camera closer on console
was one of the holy wars we had a fight
and I didn't figure it was going to be
but it was surprising to see like you
can't move the camera near the Apple
game no I think I think you can so let's
talk about controls something's pretty
obvious that a controller is not a mouse
and keyboard and what are the fears I
had going into this experiment was it
really felt that even though I was
really excited about the prospect but it
felt like I was committing we as a team
we were committing one of the greatest
heresies in gaming we're going to take
this beloved pc classic and put it on
the dirty controller right the truth is
and again this is a revelation we had as
a team remember the very first day I'm
sitting down there and what we call her
living room simulator sitting down with
control in my hand for the first time I
loaded up the Barbarian and I'm walking
not pointing and clicking I'm walking my
barbarian down the road to New Tristram
and I come across the first zombie and I
press the X button and I see and I bash
the zombie and I see a skeleton flying
across the screen that was the first
time in all my years of playing the
Apple games then instead of feeling like
Josh behind a computer clicking away
like mad I felt I was this guy I really
felt I was a badass hero the intimate
connection of direct control really
highlighted the visceral pneus that I
think is at the heart of a Diablo game
and what we learned here at the team or
we came very comfortable with is that
Diablo is not about how you control it
the Apple is about what you're doing and
what you're doing is slaying demons and
getting loot how you do that it doesn't
matter
as long as it's fast and responsive the
other sort of perspective that console
gave us resulted in adventure mode now
adventure mode is one of the things we
added with Reaper Souls and nothing
tells your community that you're
radically changing your game by adding
an entirely new way of playing the game
so where did this come from well it
actually had a start in the console
version of the game and the way we
handled the difficulty select screen now
at this point on the pc side of things
that introduced the system called
monster power monster power it allows
you to sort of throttle the difficulty
of the challenge of your game by
selecting from one to ten levels and we
were looking at it and we thought okay
that's great we really like that system
but it's not very console friendly and
in fact what it really is it's a
difficulty select screen so instead of
burying it in a drop-down why don't we
bring it up forward right make it one of
the first decisions you make as you're
loading up the game and and i think the
console players are going to feel very
it's going to feel very comfortable for
them now this was a big challenge
because again it wasn't in diablo 3 it
wasn't in diablo 2 why we adding this
level of difficulty but again we thought
they was so important for a hand-built
experience that we needed to do this now
but this ended up rolling into is that
it really started to change our thinking
when it came to difficulty now in diablo
3 at launch the difficulty of a monster
was essentially hard-coded to the area
and the overall difficulty of the game
so a skeleton in act 1 on normal had
this many hit points at this much damage
the same skeleton you know in act 1 in
inferno had more hit points and had more
did more damage and this way how wit
that's how we carefully control it so
that peaks and valleys of the difficulty
we wanted well one of the things we
start experimenting with but what if the
monsters leveled up with your character
right this will allow us to have more
dynamic encounters there was allow us to
do things like adventure mode but there
was a fear that if you're leveling up
your monsters alongside your player
level well that's just going to result
in a very sort of flat exterior
there's not going to be any peaks and
valleys well the things that we quickly
found out is that actually our items
where the right vector to give us those
peaks and valleys because when you get
an upgrade you're going to be
overpowered to the level of the monsters
that drop that item so naturally you're
going to get that cool peaks and valleys
that ebb and flow that you really wanted
to and then once we hit on that and we
serve really mastered our fear having a
very linear very flat difficulty scheme
that's what resulted in us eventually
saying you know what would be very cool
if we allow players if we unlocked all
the waypoints and allow them to go
anywhere and slay anything and again
that chain started with the way we
change difficulty in on the console
version but I think the biggest change
that the console version help us make
was what eventually became loot two
point oh so what is lu two point oh well
it's very simple we knew that we were
working on the console version there was
no way that we could be dropping as many
items as we were and still have players
not spend the entire game in the
inventory screen so we decided we have
to drop less items so this is what a
typical screenshot of what looked like
right after these three launch of when
you killed the butcher again a whole lot
of nothing but a lot of it now
fast-forward to lu two point oh and this
is what happens when you kill a rift
guardian you're getting legendaries
getting crafting materials you want but
more importantly you're getting less of
it but the stuff you're getting is
better the other thing that we really
wanted to do right and really started
taking steps of the console version but
i think it reaper really nailed it was
we wanted to make sure that your items
really change the way you play the game
essentially we wanted the item the
legendary a plexus of those items to
break the game and make you feel
overpowered and one of the things we
fixed is we did away with the notion
that sometimes a blue could be better
than a yellow and we did here the set
items the green items which are the
hardest items to find in the game should
be the most powerful items in the game
so where did this really come from from
the console standpoint so you're going
to give you guys a very sir brief
example of the types of challenges we
had as a team to really shift our
philosophy so this is a screenshot from
a very early build in the summer of 2011
again I'd only been a blizzard for a
couple of months playing a lot of d3
really getting a sense of what the game
was about I was playing a wizard at this
point and these two items drop and I'm
all for the moment I think it's the
beginning of Act two you and like oh
this is awesome and then I start looking
at them and go okay one is 71 percent
more damage to wizards cool I'm a wizard
but the other one is twenty-five
twenty-four percent more damage overall
but forty-eight percent crit chance wait
a minute which one's better I have the
advantage of being right next door to
the system designer so I walk over and
hey guys which one should I pick I mean
which one which ones really better and
that started a 45 minute discussion as
to which one was better and at that
point this alarm bells are ringing in
the back of my head because I'm
realizing that if the designers who
implemented these items who know these
systems intimately cannot agree which
item is better there's no hope in hell
that our players are going to figure
this out even with google and it also
means that the poor console player is
going to spend all this time looking at
this tiny 4 by 3 screen trying to figure
this this math problem out so we knew we
needed to do something so I thought it
was really clever you know like a lot of
times designers we think we're clever so
like I've seen this problem in other
games and this is how they fix it so we
had green arrows if it's good for you
down red hours if it's not good for you
and on PC because they're like numbers
green numbers if is good red numbers it
is bad right this way you know players
start getting to know the system they
can start making better choices better
decisions the kind of training wheels so
it's not but why don't we implement this
the first backlash was that's not on
diablo 2 why are you adding it to the
apple 3 and said well because it's
diablo 3 I mean like the item game has
increased in complexity you guys are
doing a lot of really cool things but I
also think that 10 years have gone by
and I think player
might need some training we also
understand this eventually we want that
argument but then a bigger argument came
up is okay okay fine if you need to have
your little green arrows will give you
the green arrows but then let's talk
about how you're going to figure out
what the green arrows that means you're
going to be making some assumptions
you're going to say well some affixes
are more important because you're going
to simplify it you know surfaces it just
comes down to attack toughness and
healing at that time so yes so but then
you're going to start making decisions
for the player you're going to tell them
what affixes are more important than
others and like I'm thinking to myself
okay that could be a problem but let's
really back up for a moment here and in
the game that's about killing any
effects that allows me to kill faster
and better it's going to be the right
choice over any other FX right but that
was a conversation and a realization
that took us a long time to get to
around and the things that we realized
as we're working on Reaper souls that a
lot of the fixes the team was trying to
come up to the way they were trying to
adjust and compensate for you know the
way these we launched we're only
addressing the symptoms this example
here even though you know I think it's
one of those moments where I realized
that okay there's something deep inside
the roots of this item system that is
not quite right we still weren't fixing
that we were fixing the symptoms the
cause was as I mentioned before was an
item philosophy at launch we had way too
many items we were dropping those items
across this like item curve there was
like glacier along you know go on for
decades we players didn't really
understand the concept of rarity vs
Power we committed a sin that we made
all the legendaries because we were a
little strapped for time piles of stats
as opposed to build changing and we
treated all F fixes equally this is
where a lot of the problems with the
loot system in d3 really stem from and
loot 2 point 0 is the way we try to fix
it so we wanted to drop fewer items they
wanted to be better we really need to
make the legendaries what they need
to be and this is where loot to point o
goddess so for those of you don't know
what Lou to point o is I'm just going to
go over it very quickly the first thing
we did is we had smart drops so this
quiver will not drop if you're playing a
barbarian or will drop very very very
very very very rarely we also realized
as I was mentioning before then not all
affixes are created equal so we created
two buckets we have a primary that's
really all about being more efficient at
killing and then we have a secondary one
where we add a lot of cool flavor and we
try to create tension not between
individual affixes but create tension
between these two groups of affixes we
really try to highlight the legendary
effects you know and here we really try
to do things that really fundamentally
break the game and the other thing we
did is we added this concept of quality
now one of the problems I've felt that
our players had and we had got this from
focus test is if when they would get an
item they didn't know how good that item
was and that's because we didn't show
them the Delta of the item so now when
you hold down the control key you can
actually see hey this item isn't massive
upgrade because in its in the 99th
percentile actually feel awesome about
it and you do feel awesome and then
finally the compare tool tips are still
there but they're at the bottom right
because they don't matter as much
anymore because we really addressed a
lot of the other big things they really
had was hurting the Apple 3 at launch
but even with loot two point oh we were
not done there was one more thing that
we as a team needed to do and that is
what to do with the auction house I
mentioned before this was a grand
experiment our intention and our
motivation was really to provide players
with a safe environment in which they
could trade d2 was played by account
compromises people getting the credit
card stolen their account stolen it's a
terrible user experience and even though
it's their fault I blizzard we feel as
our fault as well so we wanted to bring
that experience under the blizzard
umbrella and we thought well only about
ten percent the players will use it it
would be okay
and again because of how hard the game
was how stingy dilute was what we did we
end up like just shoving everybody into
the auction house and we knew we needed
to do something but the challenge was
that it became a Kobayashi Maru scenario
for us it was a lose-lose scenario right
we couldn't like it was already there
some players were liking it other
players hated it wanted it to remove
what when it removed it also highlighted
the fact that in a loot based game any
type of trading will fundamentally ruin
that core reward loop even if your
friend gives you this awesome item and
you love him for it all that he's done
is rob you of an X number of hours of
upgrades right so we knew we had this
really sir big big problem so remember a
couple of weeks after the console
version shipped we had our you know
monthly d3 strategy meeting with mike
moore haim and essentially all the
leadership of blizzard and the topic
that day was because of hearthstone
coming out because the heroes of the
storm coming out we needed to do some
changes to the way the backend system of
cashing out worked so there was talk
about you know so what to do with the
auction house and how to how to make
this changes and the meeting hunt gone
on for about 20 minutes there was a lot
of business talk a lot of legal talk so
I was off thinking about you know how to
slay demons and and you know how to be
an epic hero and doodling and at that
point Mike Moore I'm notices that I
haven't said anything and says well Josh
you're awfully quiet what do you think
we should do I'm like busted what are we
talking about the auction house now I'm
getting and so I thought to myself okay
I could say what I think it's a safe
answer right we can sort of say like
okay maybe make small changes we had a
bunch of proposals in terms of how to
try to limit the impact of the auction
house by making items less tradable and
all these things got all these really
complex systems and we thought we were
okay with those compromises but then I
sort of said you know what actually
really speak what I think is the right
thing to do so said Mike I think what we
need to do
with whom we need to shut down both the
real money and the gold auction house I
mean people played the a blow to slay
all the things I guess and you know what
the awesome thing was that 20 minutes
later everyone in that room was fully on
board with this idea you know it wasn't
this big protracted fight between the
business skies on the game design guys
know everybody a blizzard understood
that the most important thing for our
game is to preserve the integrity of the
game experience that a game like Diablo
needs to be a game about killing
monsters and slaying demons not shopping
for loot so three days later we made the
announcement in six months after that
the auction house was gone and I think
this was one of the key moments where we
signaled I mean not just to our
community that was really important but
we signal it to ourselves and the rest
of blizzard that we were going to change
the hablo and we're going to try to make
it better or we were going to die trying
so where are we now so back then when we
shipped it was all about efficiency
fantasy wasn't important even from a
teens perspective you wouldn't often
hear what's the fantasy behind that
skill why does that matter now for
Reaper souls and going forward fantasy
comes first right and one we've
expressed this is to make sure that our
legendaries our game breaking in diablo
2 at throwing elbow three you would shop
not play because that was the most
efficient way of getting items when
reaper souls we shut down the auction
house we added lu two point oh and in
diablo 3 it was all about flip farming
it was finding they'll kaiser runs and
dumb over and over and over again and
with reaper souls we made variety the
most efficient way of playing the game
and that's why we added adventure mode
that's why I adventure mode
fundamentally changes the experience of
the game so this brings me to maybe a
few takeaways that you guys can take
from this from this talk again this has
been an incredible journey for the
diablo team
we learned a lot of really hard lessons
but the best thing about this team is
that we never gave up on each other we
believed we could do it and we did and
think going forward some of those
lessons that I'm going to have scars for
the rest of my life are going to be the
first one is the importance of pillars I
mean you notice in this talk that I
presented two sets of pillars focus on
the fantasy and any game for everyone
make online matter for Reaper pick up
and slay hand built for the console and
lung Calculon offer for console and it's
so really important that you are able to
express to your team to yourself what
the inherent DNA of your game is these
don't have to be clever catchphrases
they just need to be true that they need
to help you focus and make decisions
right they need to help you give you
that clarity that when you're fighting
fires you know and there's incoming fire
overhead and things get crazy like they
always do you need to go to your pillars
right you need to have a few of them
right not 20 no more than five I like
three that's a personal choice the other
one that I think we took a long time to
learn as you got to know your fears okay
now every single one of us has creative
people as game designers we make
assumptions about how a game how a
system is going to work and a lot of
those assumptions are really based off
our fears what are we scared of what do
we what don't we know and one and the
two fears that came back over and over
on d3 and that we still had to keep
fighting in reaper souls first woman is
that's not Diablo that we were so afraid
that we wouldn't live up to the legacy
of Diablo that we kept making decisions
that kind of in the end and their
resulting in that and it wasn't the
Reaper souls that we really understood
what the inherent circor a Reaper was
the other fear that we had as an item
based game was that we were afraid to be
too generous because everybody knows in
the loop based game that people like
loop based games because they keep
coming back right you know just feeding
this awesome stuff to them and they keep
coming back and having a
good time and so there was a sphere of
like well if we give them everything
they're going to start playing and I
think the realization we made now
another thing we firmly believe now is
it is much better for players to get all
the loot and leave your game happy
because they will come back when you
have an expansion or when you do a new
DLC draw up or a new patch they will
come back happy if you're stingy and
you're afraid of being too generous
they're going to leave frustrated you're
going to spend three hours not getting
an upgrade and said like this game just
wasted my time so we really needed to be
comfortable being generous the other one
was that randomness is not replayability
I talked about this a little bit before
but this was one of those like aha
moments where we realized that we
sacrificed so much at the altar of
randomness that we lost we lost sight of
fun this is why we have systems where if
you haven't gotten a legendary in a
certain amount of time you know we make
sure that we slowly start nudging the
system to make sure you do get a drop
you know we varied subtle with it but I
think it's really important that we
understand that what we want is
replayability we want people to come
back random iskcon sometimes push people
away and this one's really big
especially for me that you everybody
needs to keep track of what the fantasy
is the reason this is important for me
is because we constantly need to ask
ourselves why this matter for our
players why do they care why are they
playing my game versus another game and
it doesn't matter what kind of game
you're working on there's always a
fantasy there you're always trying to
transport your player into a different
world you're trying to immerse them
whether it's in the mechanics or the
aesthetics it doesn't matter you're
trying to immerse them and the only way
to do that is by making sure that the
fantasy is first and foremost the final
lesson and this is a very personal
lesson it's your teams that define
success Wendy 3 ship that the Apple team
should have been on cloud nine the
reviews are all first of all it's done
right the reviews are awesome the cells
are astronomical but remember that day
walking through the halls of the the
diablo team area and it felt like a
funeral because we knew that we had let
everybody else down because success for
us is not about the sales or what
critics saying success for us means our
players happy playing our game and they
weren't and what i'm most proud of that
we've accomplished as a team is that
we've really turned around player
sentiment people are having fun playing
diablo they love coming back four
seasons we're now merging the console
family of players with the pc family of
players and now it's a really good time
to be at the apple player so before I
close I also want to say a really huge
thanks to the Diablo team it's an honor
working with you guys and we fought
together I also want to take a moment to
really thank ray gresko who was the
original production director for d3 for
building that also team and Jay Wilson
for laying down the foundation that
allowed us to make these kind of awesome
changes with Reaper Souls we wouldn't be
here right now if it wasn't for the work
of the team so I really want to thank
them and I want to thank you guys for
listening to my talk thank
so I believe we have a couple minutes
for questions so I would love to answer
questions if you have any balance
questions I'll answer them afterwards
Alex hi Josh you know so thanks for the
talk so you basically mentioned the
tension between to their personas the
old guard the new guard so my question
is does it the tension comes from the
fact that we're dealing with the way
bigger audience than before is it
because now the audience has access to
the Internet is it because we're getting
old or maybe is it because gasp the more
streamlined and more visceral experience
driven by a console design and actually
be of some value and it was a good
question i think i think the answer is a
bit of all of it i think one of the
things that as a team we realized we
were slow to adjust so diablo was not
one of the first lieut games was one of
the first sir games had really made it
sir mass market and popular and in the
ten years between diablo 2 and diablo 3
our players thinking about loot games
really evolved I mean world of warcraft
all these games really started changing
the way they they felt about about about
luke and one of the things that you know
we didn't as a team fully adjust as well
to that but yeah it's a good question
right i can't see people all right we'll
go over there because there's one you
hey i'm just curious how a relatively
new guy on the team became game director
in such a short time yeah I i don't know
and i don't know i'm at any moment i'm
sure they're going to ask me to leave
you know
it's a hard portion to answer I think
she has asked my ask might ask my team
so when the position was was open I
originally wasn't going to apply for it
I was actually happy just being a lead
designer again I used to be a creative
director & design director a lot of
studios and like I was really just happy
like having my small problems to deal
with but I looked out at our team and I
really love the diablo team and I really
wanted to sort of take care of them and
keep them you know together and start
moving forward so I decided to bite the
bullet and apply and I was actually
pretty shocked that they said yes you
can you can do this so even today I'm
sort of like incredibly privileged to be
here so thanks I went to 22 sorry to go
back to what you said about the beta
test after april three and how basically
as leading the the information about the
problem that you find out when you ship
the game more and more game now we know
the try to engage our community early on
and almost develop the game with the
community and getting the feedback and
what they want to see in the game do see
something that do you think it's going
to be something that happens are going
to do in the future meaning like
engaging people already on to validate
your what you're doing again in the
design or do you keep like more like
doing the game and then you do better
than at the end then you ship like the
remodel no i think one of the things we
really shifted is we really started
doing a lot of what we called PTR or
public test realm so in fact right now
you know we have the public test realm
for the the patches coming up because
totally like the more that our players
are playing the game especially the more
dedicated players the better the
feedback we're getting the earlier we're
getting we're getting that that that
feedback and community has always been a
really important thing with
blizzard-like blizzcon is one extension
of it but you know we're really open and
we try to get as much feedback as
possible even the really negative bitter
stuff thank you thank you okay so when a
reaper of souls launched and it had the
dynamic difficulty where you could kind
of change on the fly I thought this was
a really good way to fix the diablo 3
very rigid difficulty but I noticed that
a lot of players like I would talk to on
Twitter would say I'm starting this on
normal and I'm playing all the way
through normal and it's too easy but I
refuse to change how I deal with that
difficulty did you feel like you had
trouble kind of retraining players to
notice the difficulty was something they
should change on the fly we did we did
and I still think it's not something
we've nailed either and I think is one
of those systems that you know if you
have to redo it we probably find more
sort of more dynamic ways of doing it so
they just it just naturally try to scale
it up or scaly down on you by paying
attention to what you're doing as a
player alright we got two more minutes
so rapid-fire hi so first of all I
started with Reaper of souls on the
console and it's great thank you very
much I just have a question do you guys
plan on eventually trying to unify the
experience between console and PC so
what we're trying to do is so one of the
things we're doing now is when we're
releasing our patch on PC we release it
on console as well but in order for us
to really deliver that awesome
experience on both platforms we really
try to treat them as separate games and
one of the challenges of unifying them
as I mentioned before we've changed so
many of the skills that even though they
look like the same game underneath the
hood two very different games right so
is it would be impossible to actually
like unify it that way we want to make
sure that as a community that both
evolving in the same lockstep manner
Thanks hi looking at this new features
like gems and greater rifts I wanna just
wondering why you prefer to put some new
PvE features rather than trying to put
some pvp on the game um because
everybody keeps asking us when PvP is
going to go in and we yet to figure out
how to make a fun PvP experience but we
wanted to have some competitive element
to it so we felt that was something that
was missing but again it's it's it's
we're sort of evolving the game right
and right now we're still in that
process of really having fun
and trying to change it thanks are at
last portion okay so there's kind of a
funny Internet picture of valve meeting
notes step one more hats step two
everything is tradable which is the
opposite of Diablo fewer hats nothing is
tradable do you think that there's kind
of a future of that whimsical player
based trading system in the Diablo
franchise no no yeah who knows but I
again I really fundamentally believe
that any kept any type of trading in a
loot based game essentially
short-circuits what's fun about the game
which is killing now if it's a game of
about social trading then that's ok if
that's a primary way of getting items
rock but if it's as long as it's about
killing and questing you have to be
doing actions to get those items right
so what we can just obviously a lot more
we can talk about this but again thank
you guys and we're down to 10 seconds
[Music]